Hello Freak bitches.
It is what it was.
Just like any other problem that people go back to.
I mean at some point it's up to you to release yourself from that obligation to
get upset or feel bad about something that didn't go right in the past,
you know?
And uh,
that's a huge point because people define themselves by the past instead of
thinking about who they are now instead of they still look back at a mistake
they made and don't just get past that mistake,
grow and learn,
but dwell on it.
I think it defines them.
That's the worst thing.
I met some guys that band and he says,
is it singers?
I've only met him twice,
two different times,
years later.
Both Times.
He started telling me about the story,
about what happened to him when he was in this.
Anything in this poor guy is gone on all these years and he's still focused on
the worst situation that he ever had to live through.
Yeah.
And so a attached to it,
well some guys get one break up and they're done.
Some guys,
one breakup in their twenties will tank them for a decade.
I've met guys like that that,
yeah.
You know,
I came out here with Shelly and you know,
she fuckin fell in love with their trainer and dude,
Sally still move on.
What is that?
And fucking years ago,
oh well,
you know,
change my life bro.
But to tell you I was so disappointed I can't trust women anymore.
Oh,
you stupid.
Fuck.
You know what?
What if he got mugged by one person who'd done trust in people?
If you get exactly one person was a murderer,
let's not trust anybody.
Yeah,
yeah.
You know,
I heard about Ted Bundy.
I'm not trusting people anymore.
Oh,
okay,
great.
I'm not sleeping tonight.
We,
yeah,
I mean there's definitely pitfalls in life.
You're going to run into him.
We all are.
You can learn and grow.
If you survive it,
pick yourself up,
it,
dust the dust off,
and then you start going,
don't let this stuff.
Well,
let it beat you down.
It's also directly proportionate to the amount of hardships that people face in
life.
Their ability to face hardships.
You know?
And there's a lot of folks that live life on a cushy cloud of marshmallows and
bullshit and then one day something goes wrong and I mean that's why s spoiled
kids are so sad.
Like a spoiled young boy is one of the saddest things ever.
A young boy that becomes a man and can't take care of himself and his dad has to
keep on rescuing him.
His Dad has to keep on bailing them out of situations and giving them money.
I've met guys like that and that is a crippling affliction when they don't have
the character themselves to be able to get by in life.
They constantly need someone to help them and bail them out.
Even as a grown man,
I've met guys in their forties it's still need help from their parents.
I'm like,
what the fuck man,
you're never going to get it right because somewhere along the line they didn't
face enough of the university to realize that there's sometimes you just got to
get up and get shit done.
There's sometimes we have to fucking pull yourself up and you have to push
forward,
even if you want to stay in bed.
And if you don't do that and he just keep calling on your daddy and your daddy
keeps rescuing you,
you never developed those tools,
you never developed that ability to recognize what you're doing wrong with your
life because you're,
you're soft.
You got Cushnie,
you've got a safety net,
a safety net for safety net.
I have this friend and she has this,
uh,
this friend that she's been friends with for decades and this poor fuck his
family,
super,
super wealthy,
like unbelievable wealthy,
billions of dollars.
And he had not only did he had,
uh,
he had a trust fund and a backup trust fund.
So he blew through the trust fund and then he blew through the backup trust
fund,
real estate investments and just disastrous business ventures.
No character,
no discipline,
no ability to stick it out,
but incredible amount of resources.
He had millions and millions of dollars,
just pissed it all away,
didn't understand it,
completely depressed.
And one day said to her,
he said,
you know,
cause she has children as well and she has sons.
He said to her,
he goes,
whatever you do,
do not give your kids money.
Don't give them a fucking penny.
He goes,
especially boys,
don't give them a penny that,
that ruined me.
Don't give him money.
And I was wondering,
wow,
that's deep shit to be a man.
Like in your late forties looking back at your life,
this disaster wreckage that you've put forth,
the millions you've blown now he has like a retail job.
His parents abandoned them.
I mean you'll,
you'll look at that and you go,
Whoa,
this is,
this is wild shit man.
It's a guy.
It's just still struggling from the way he was developed from the,
the tools that were instilled in him at a childhood.
And then,
you know,
in adolescence and having that safety net just provided him with a way to stay
in bed,
kept him week,
never developed character now or the [inaudible] have an opportunity.
Every time things go wrong.
Every time things feel terrible,
you have an opportunity to learn from whatever makes you feel terrible and never
allow it to happen again.
Exactly.
Yeah.
Thank you.
That's forward.
Don't,
don't do it again.
Yeah.
You know,
learn from your mistakes.
We all make them.
That's where meditation comes in.
Recognizing that and solidifying it and your head and the,
I believe meditation,
the tank,
which is a more magnified form of meditation.
I think it's more intense and I think that you can,
you could really get something out of that if with those sort of ideas in your
mind about constant,
consistent improvement and it's only the only thing that you'll allow from
yourself just to maintain a certain standard.
Then consistently trying to improve and do that,
do that and you'll be,
you'll be a happier person.
That's an amazing concept there to become a part of to where you're involved in,
you're the Osha instruction of your own character.
Yes.
It's through your own efforts and your own evaluation and then two,
to make the right steps and make the right decisions that to become even
stronger as you go.
Okay.